- Okay, so we met some of your alter egos
last time you were on the show,
you know, when we can
see people in person,
but have you developed any new characters,
because quarantine would
provide you time for that?
Well, I didn't, I haven't
developed any new characters,
but there was a resurgence of one of my,
Oh my God, hold on one second.
He can join us.
Watch this.
- Okay.
I love her.
She's so great.
(laughing)
- Okay, so this is Mikhail.
My name is Mikhail.
And I make videos with him.
And at the beginning of the pandemic,
yeah, there he is at the
beginning of the pandemic.
Let's cross his legs so he can.
- He's sophisticated.
- Yeah, he wore his mask.
- [Mikhail] But I do it for my people.
(laughing)
- I love you.
- Yeah, Mikhail, maybe he'll join us
for the rest of this conversation.
- I love his legs crossed.
It's the little touches.
God is in the details.
That's awesome!